[Music]
you're one of the nicer people i've met
in show business but man you play mean
so well that you must have people
convinced that you really are mean well
you know in order to play it it's got to
be you've seen me mean and mad yeah yeah
but it's usually behind people's back
exactly yeah exactly
you know yeah i think it's just not far
from the surface and this is i'm a great
advocate for therapy good therapy um
when you can look at that stuff you can
look at your own anger and you can laugh
at it then you can use it for your art i
mean before before i kind of looked at
it in therapy
it wasn't something that i could use as
a you know something for my artistic
expression if you will and um you know i
got a handle on it now
yeah
what's nice is i would think on after a
day of shooting glee
with your character you must have just
feel lighter than air you get so there's
so much hate out of you exactly i'm a
sweetheart at home yeah because i get i
get it out in the track suit i want to
ask you back
i wanna
i wanna we found this picture of you
this was in uh out magazine and it's you
i gotta ask you what's going on here in
clown makeup i love the photograph yeah
i do too you know i kept that makeup on
because i don't like to wash my face i
like to do i just like to get home and
so i always go home with a full face of
makeup so i went home with that makeup
on and you know that cigarette hanging
out of my mouth yeah well i don't smoke
anymore but it's so awakened the
addiction inside of me that on my way
home i pulled over and smoked it
but you have the cl you had this still
the clown makeup on yeah
i pulled over on fountain at um i know
exactly where that is in los angeles and
west
west hollywood just like anyone just
pulling over and you're just you're just
there in clown makeup smoking a
cigarette i also like that you
considered the the cigarette hanging out
like well i gotta leave it in to drive
home yeah like you couldn't just take it
out and throw it away no no no and i
took a pack of matches we were at a
hotel and i snuck out of there and i
felt so naughty and i couldn't wait to
find a place to pull over now
in the clown makeup
i love that you feel naughty after
stealing some matches
which are free in the same way i'm
always at a restaurant and i take one
they're in a bowl and i'm a catholic
thing too i take one and then i'm just
like
they're gonna stop me at the door i know
i took a paper towel